Yeah.
So thank you for the invitation.
It's great to be here.
Thanks for coming.
So as Richard mentioned,
uh,
I am a senior lecturer at the University of Technology Sydney.
Um,
but I'm also a children's book author and I'm also a father and it's kind of
summed up in this most common question I get from other academics.
So this is a stock photo of a sciencey looking person and that's not their real
name,
but the email itself is,
is one that I've received.
It says,
uh,
I'm also a scientist and I happened to be an aspiring author as well.
Uh,
you've written dozens of children's books,
so starting with quantum physics for babies,
uh,
which was published mid last year,
and now the latest is astrophysics for babies.
Um,
and there's some picture books in there as well,
and you have four kids and an active academic career.
Um,
so what is your secret?
And I thought that was a funny question.
You know,
my secret,
I thought any answer to that would be kind of like an infomercial.
So initially,
you know,
I didn't give an answer,
I didn't think about it.
I just had,
you know,
hard work and a little bit of luck and you'll get there.
And speaking of luck,
you know,
I get to travel all around the world as an academic talking about quantum
physics.
Um,
you know,
I talked to students giving lectures and other researchers.
I get to talk to business leaders and entrepreneurs about quantum technology.
But since becoming an author now,
I talked to science enthusiasts,
um,
high school students,
elementary school students,
teachers,
journalists,
and even now because the books are for babies,
parents and toddlers.
And I received lots of questions obviously,
but quantum physics,
which is unsurprising,
but what I didn't expect,
where question is about my personal life and my philosophy towards parenting.
So parents really want to know,
okay,
how do you really teach kids quantum physics?
Um,
and the questions are kind of phrase in this,
what's your,
what's the secret sort of way?
And these are difficult obviously to answer it because,
well,
there's not really an easy answer or even an answer at all to such a question.
Um,
but in trying to brides some answer that was honest and as concise as possible,
uh,
something kind of started to coalesce in my mind after answering all these
questions.
So there's this old saying,
it's kind of cliche.
If you don't know where you came from,
then you can't know where you're going.
So I thought maybe there's some truth to that.
Um,
maybe I've been too busy as an academic trying to publish and work through the
system,
building a marriage,
building a family that,
you know,
I never really stopped and thought about,
what,
what was it about my up bringing that allowed me to do this?
Maybe there,
there was a secret.
Um,
and if there was then a,
I should maybe be more thoughtful in using those tools that I've developed in my
upgrade,
bringing with my own children.
So I kind of thought about it.
I have a pretty bad memory and I don't really remember much about my childhood,
but luckily,
um,
my parents took lots of pictures and lots of videos.
So I,
I bothered my mom,
but I guess not really because I probably don't call her enough.
So definitely,
definitely call your mom.
Uh,
I got some old home videos from my dad and set to it and I think what I found
was kind of a common thread that I going to tell you about today.
The story in doing my research probably starts a bit earlier though with my
grandfather.
So he served briefly as a radio operator in World War II and then he stayed in
radio his whole life and he dabbled in all sorts of aspects of radio including
hosting and then eventually advertising.
But the way I remember him was like in his retirement where he just always had
this experience where he wanted to perfect his surroundings in terms of sound.
So he always had this,
the best sound system in his,
in his apartment and he just loved these devices that produce sound.
And I think that's what led to my father being kind of a tinkerer of electronics
as well.
My living room going up had like these ever evolving handcrafted sound systems.
The house was full of electronics,
but you know,
I'm surrounded by electronics here today and not like these kinds of connected
devices.
It was exposed wires and DIY gadgets.
These were my dad's toys,
but he wasn't a licensed electrician.
In fact,
I don't think he's formerly trained in anything,
but that didn't stop him from being called what was known as a Jack of all
trades.
And so I see some young people in the audience today think,
you know,
if he were my age today than he would have a big beard and Tattoo and you'd find
them at them makerspace building a custom gear for fixed fee or something like
that.
Um,
but the point is,
he built stuff and it was using whatever materials were available.
And as you could see from the clip,
you know,
safety really wasn't much of a concern.
So just put a clamp on a desk and attach a link to it and that'll be the light
for the kids.
And so really I saw firsthand what it was to play with things that weren't
marketed and packaged as toys and play with things in ways that other people
hadn't thought of before.
My brother and I joined my dad in the shop,
which was the garage,
and we were wiring and cutting and hammering and painting.
That is one of his homemade speakers there,
and I actually still remember and can prove that I got cut by that reciprocal
saw.
There's a little fading scar,
but then there was a shift,
right?
So
the consumer electronics started to get cheaper and these DIY gadgets were
replaced by electronic chips that were covered in plastic in the late eighties
personal computers became affordable for middle class income families,
and I had access to Ataris and commodores and Nintendo's Sega has and eventually
personal computers and the Internet.
And what this shift entailed was something entirely new.
No longer did I play with the wires and the physical things,
the hardware.
Now I played with software and as an added bonus,
having a twin brother,
I had to become a rather robust user.
I think he had to be a little bit more robust than I did.
So I was an early adopter of many new gadgets and that include the gadgets with
software.
I wouldn't say I came of age with the personal computer.
I think that is a bit too early.
That's Gen X.
I'm kind of at the cusp.
I'm an elder millennial maybe.
Um,
so those were the people that needed to learn to code,
to use personal computers.
Those were my friends,
older siblings I came of age with graphical user interfaces,
not lines of computer code.
And I'm talking about the kinds of software that my generation grew up with and
that our parents had to use in their office jobs.
So windows,
a word,
processors and spreadsheets,
quickbooks,
Photoshop and eventually web browsers and all of our smartphone apps.
And I played with software the same way I watched my dad play with his
electronic toys and tools.
So this here is the very first home video on the set that my dad gave me.
And what you can see is that rather than for its intended use,
like film your family,
he just starts goofing around and playing with it and probably like in a way
that the designers really never intended.
And so I've inherited this behavior.
I open a toy or gadget and immediately and uncontrollably start testing and
trying to figure out how it works without reading the instructions.
So more often than not,
I can kind of get it to work within a few minutes and occasionally I find some
new and interesting use for it.
So the entirety of my life has been this user tester tinker and eventually
builder of software.
And I think there's an APP name for this as well.
A hacker,
the 21st century version of the Jack of all trades.
Of course we're all users of software today,
but this hacker mentality is difficult to achieve and understand because
software today is designed to be real robust against this exact behavior.
So developers and the companies they work for or don't necessarily want users to
play with their software in ways they don't intend,
they want to.
I think perhaps avoid those one star reviews on the APP store because it has to
work fast and it has to work almost in an expected way.
And perhaps you've seen people on the bus just doing this motion over and over
and over again.
So this isn't the kind of play that I'm talking about,
right?
People play with software today.
All right.
Again,
when their smart phones,
you know,
think flappy bird or crossy road,
when this is the only thing that you do with the software.
I'm talking about software where you have this freedom to only follow your own
curiosity,
um,
in playing with it.
And so in terms of that play,
I think the single waking activity I've done most in my life is play with
software.
And I think this is the secret.
This is my secret.
My Dad was a jack of all trades and I am a jack of all software,
a hacker.
And to make this a little more concrete,
uh,
I'm going to give you a few snapshots over the many years of how I've used
software with this hacker mentality in mind.
So,
uh,
let's go back to high school.
The Internet wasn't a big thing in suburban Canada until the late,
the late nineties.
Of course when the first Internet access store opened up and there was an
affordable option,
my dad was an early adopter and a perhaps you might remember the sound,
which is like burned into my mind.
All right,
that's enough of that.
So my high school of course I understand Internet access,
like all high schools,
whatever,
but it was in the library and not very many people used it.
If you wanted to do a webpage,
how it worked back then was somebody somehow found out about a webpage,
maybe through some links to from other web pages.
And if you wanted someone else to know about that one patient and you'd have to,
you know,
write down in the web address on a piece of paper and then they would go to
internet explorer or Netscape and type that address in and Voila,
they would see the web page.
Uh,
if you didn't know that address then,
then you would never see the webpage.
But then,
uh,
one thing came along.
Does anyone remember?
Web Color?
Uh,
I feel maybe I don't need to lecture you here on the history of,
of Internet search.
Uh,
but just in case this was the kind of precursor to Google,
uh,
this is an archive of screenshot from 1996 I believe.
And um,
by the way,
if you thought like fake news and conspiracy theories are a recent sort of
phenomenon,
have a look at the example that you should search in like the one of the first
search engines ever.
Alien abduction Ufo Roswell.
So a web crawler I gave kind of terrible search results,
but you know,
it's one of the first search engines.
Um,
I checked actually it's still works.
You can go to [inaudible] dot com and the first thing I searched for and web
color.com was Google.
And the first hit is Amazon.
Um,
which is,
which is a bit strange,
but maybe not.
Um,
so I don't need to tell you here about the kind of technology today that goes
into the kind of seemingly simple task of web search.
But back then it was more difficult.
You had to be what I would call a search engine hacker.
I mean look at the example why,
you know,
why would you have to put alien abduction in quotation marks,
but Ufo Roswell,
not in quotation marks.
So these are the kind of like tricks that you had to play back then.
Whereas now I type one letter,
I haven't even decided what I want to search for and you guys have figured out
already that what I want to search for it.
Um,
so,
uh,
I think there was like this brief brief terminology shortly after Google before,
you know,
search really became kind of this intuitive thing.
Google food.
I don't know if you guys remember that.
Uh,
it almost disappears as fast as it arrived.
And so I had this,
this kind of Google Fu in high school and I was one of the very few people that
use a web search to complete my assignments and kind of a,
as an added bonus.
If you were,
you know,
relatively good at computers than you are a teenager,
um,
you could use your web search skills for some other things.
But,
uh,
I didn't include a slide for that.
So,
um,
I used like a map once to drive to one of the Carolinas.
Um,
it was kind of awful.
The map,
I mean,
most of my driving has been local and for that I don't use maps.
I've never actually picked out and unfolded one of these real real maps.
Dotcom was in full swing by the time I got my first driver's license.
And I use this old but again still exist in website,
mapquest.
And if you go and you look at it,
it looks the same pretty much as mapping software today.
You can pan and zoom and you could ask it for directions and it would get you
from a to B.
But you know,
that wasn't really necessarily what you wanted.
You wanted the fastest route,
the shortest route,
a route that didn't contain traffic or a route that contained a new streets or
an old alley that was never part of the map.
Um,
and so what you had to do was kind of hack the root,
right?
And in doing so,
you had to be the one that was,
you know,
really kind of looking and panning around and optimizing it.
So today,
you know,
mapping software is much,
much better for driving directions.
But I wouldn't say it is for walking directions and I'm hoping that it's not
like a news flash that perhaps in other parts of the world,
people still still walk to places.
I've noticed that there's a lot of cars in America,
so I use Google maps in,
in and walking around Australia,
um,
for walking directions.
But oftentimes it misses things,
right?
I mean,
you have a campus here,
so you'll know,
uh,
that there are pathways that you want to take say that are well trodden through,
you know,
fields that aren't just don't show up on a map.
And so you have to sort of manually change your route.
And the thing is,
I don't feel like I ever had an innate sense of direction.
I don't think that that's really a thing.
But through practice I've developed a pretty good sense of direction.
And that practice is only available through the ability to play with software.
Like Google maps and something.
I,
by looking at the area here just this morning,
I found out just,
but you know,
looking at my local area and then,
and then zooming out,
I found out that currently I'm further north than where I grew up in Canada,
which is I think,
so it was surprising to me and I think,
um,
maybe surprising to you cause you normally use in Canada is,
oh,
Canada's north of here,
but in this case it's south southwest.
And again,
today I'm kind of losing this practice because now I kind of just showed up my
phone,
right?
Like,
okay,
Google,
uh,
navigate home,
right?
And losing this,
this,
uh,
practice with software,
is I feel like it's kind of okay because,
you know,
these are all the software that I've used in the past.
And now,
you know,
as I moved to different jobs,
I'm using different kinds of software.
And as a university lecturer and researcher,
I use all sorts of various software.
And in fact,
now I have to create software.
So it's quite small.
But there you see,
maybe you recognize some python code where I'm answering scientific questions.
So the code,
the software that have created above produces an answer to a scientific question
that you see below.
And then I use latech and other,
a bit of software and the whole chain of software to produce academic papers.
So I as academics,
we,
we write the code that creates the journal articles and then I use other
software including the software that didn't work so well just second ago,
um,
to create presentations to present those results to my colleagues.
And so that whole chain,
I'm using all of this software and in many cases,
you know,
I'm the creator software.
And as someone who's,
as an academic,
who's not really trained in software development,
I would say it's very much hacking your way through it.
And B,
being able to use software efficiently in this way really set you ahead in a
field where it's,
it's,
it's not,
it's not common,
right?
Not every academic,
even,
uh,
would touch a line of code,
when I'm not in the office.
So in the evenings I have a hobby as you can see from the stack of books.
I write children's books and unsurprisingly it makes use of software.
This software here,
uh,
maybe recognize it,
it's called Inkscape.
So it's a free and open source piece of software and I'm quite sure that it's
intended purpose was not to create a picture books for children and I buy,
you know,
being able to use the software which I use in my research to create scientific
diagrams.
I can make myself appear like an artist even though as you can see I'm just
manipulating geometric shapes and and vectors.
Okay.
This image is a part of good night lab,
which was my first picture book that was published by source books and I'm quite
proud to say that I know and their,
their design team enough that when they respond to my emails anyways,
they also using Inkscape now even though they hadn't heard of it before.
And speaking of publishing,
I actually use some translation software to negotiate my first international
book contract.
Uh,
at the time I was self published and didn't know anything about publishing.
So I contacted some,
some publishers in China using,
I think it was Google translate or I'll say it's Google translate anyways,
since I'm here
and in using translation software,
uh,
now I actually write children's books directly for,
for the Chinese market.
Okay.
And so,
um,
my response would be,
you know,
dear anonymous,
handsome sciencey looking guy,
I have an answer for you.
Of course,
you know,
I don't manage alone.
I have an amazing family and amazing partner,
but I also have software and without the efficient use and ability to play with
software,
the first book,
Quantum Physics for babies certainly wouldn't exist.
And as you saw,
all of my other illustrated books wouldn't exist and even my entire academic
career wouldn't exist.
Am I?
I think that's due to my upbringing.
So,
which was kind of perfect for making use of this evolving technology.
But these successes are kind of a product of that unique environment,
culture and opportunities that I was given.
And so I have to thank my parents for that.
But the problem with success stories is that they're very hard to repeat,
right?
So we don't have that same environment.
And culture today.
So as a parent myself,
I can't repeat the same thing that my parents did,
but I can kind of use this spirit that is,
I can give my children experiences and opportunities to play with tools and
technology.
But that is not enough.
I think the real lesson from my childhood story is that children will be
attracted to the ideas and the mannerisms and activities that their parents or
their teachers or their friends show a genuine interest in this today's sort of,
uh,
educational,
um,
conversation.
We're always talking about stem,
science and technology and engineering,
mathematics.
And I'm not too worried about my own children's interest in stem because they
see me showing enthusiasm for it are constantly.
But I want to give you kind of an example of the theme,
which is that my children don't really see me doing science much anymore cause
I,
I'm doing that in the office.
And then when I'm at home,
I'm working on children's books.
So they see me writing books more than they see me doing science.
And so I was quite amused,
but in hindsight,
not all that surprised when like my children would show up in the morning and
they will say,
I made this,
you know,
I made a book because they see,
they see daddy making books and the tools are,
are actually quite easy to find and without any sort of,
you know,
I never thought to have them write,
write books.
You know,
I encouraged them to do science and do experiments,
but,
but now they show up reading books.
Uh,
another amusing story is that I once gave a presentation,
kind of a more choreographed presentation at a,
at a,
at the world science festival in Brisbane where I was on stage trying to inspire
high school students to,
to,
uh,
get a job in,
in,
in science.
You know,
the,
the title was cool jobs and,
uh,
my four year old son was watching and afterward he said to me,
Daddy,
maybe when you grow up you can actually do science and not just talk about
science.
So I'm a bit worried that,
you know,
I'm not,
uh,
demonstrating the practice of science enough.
I'm wondering,
you know,
the parents are asking these questions about,
this the secret,
how do I,
you know,
I read the books and h w what's next?
Right?
How do I continue along this path?
And I wonder what sort of interests and curiosities they're instilling in their
children and what opportunities and experiences they are giving to them and what
they're kind of showing them with genuine interest.
So I want to tell you about one more thing that I'm interested in that my
children I think are uniquely placed to take advantage of if they so wish.
Uh,
so maybe I should have had like a sound for this.
Welcome to the quantum realm.
Quantum physics,
um,
has sort of a reputation for being a mysterious thing.
But the way I like to explain it in kind of a,
the least sort of mystical way to perfect group of,
of technology minded people is that it's just a mathematical theory that works
well for some physical phenomenon and not so well or not so conveniently with
others.
So it's a mathematical theory that works well when physical things are very well
isolated from an environment.
So if you can identify some region of the world that's isolated from its
environment,
then describing that with this mechanism of quantum physics will work really
well.
And Adam's,
when you think about it,
they're very well isolated.
I mean everything you know is mostly space and these atoms are very far away
from any other atom or a particle.
And so that's why quantum physics works really well to describe them.
Now what we're doing today is trying to build massive quantum technology
devices.
And again,
the only reason or or,
or the only way it will be well described by quantum physics is,
is if we can isolate these things from their environment.
Okay,
great.
But you might think,
what is quantum done for me lately?
Well,
in fact,
quantum physics is the most precise and well studied theory of science that we
have to date.
And it's the basis for pretty much all the technology that we enjoy today.
So the GPS,
like that map I showed you requires precise timing afforded by atomic clocks,
atomic clocks themselves as the word Adam right in it.
So obviously quantum physics plays a role in that.
There's a medical scan there.
So that involves looking at the spins of uh,
nuclear atoms in the body.
We have lasers which write and read on to combat this.
And CDS.
Quantum states of light are required to send signals through fiber optic cables
across huge distances,
connect all of us by the Internet.
And what are these things connecting?
They're connecting computers,
the billions upon billions of transistors that are around us in the world today.
And the only reason that we can do that is because of our understanding of
semiconductor physics,
which is based on,
on quantum mechanics.
But today,
uh,
we're doing something a little bit different.
All of that was based on big things like,
um,
things that you can see in touch with your hand.
And the kind of quantum physics that plays a role there is,
uh,
what's describing a lot of quantum things that are behaving all in the same way.
Now we have access to individual quantum systems.
So on the right hand side you see,
uh,
an ion trap that can trap individual atoms and for certain ions you can actually
see them.
So I got a chance to go to a lab in Innsbrook and could see a single atom
fluorescing.
Um,
but for the most part you of course you can't see these things.
And so the pictures we drive them or kind of our artists interpretation
on the right is a super conducting quantum device,
which is the kind that Google builds.
This one's from IBM.
And so each sort of pattern you see there is for artificial quantum Adams.
And we're,
what we're trying to do now is use quantum physics for,
you know,
in its full power to develop new technology to create new devices.
And probably the holy grail of this research is a quantum computer which would
solve existing problems that are just not solvable today and probably will solve
problems that we haven't even thought of.
This is just one of many emerging technologies.
So I want to give you kind of an analogy for what,
say a child growing up today might experience any kind of a lesson,
if you will.
From my,
the secret that I had when I asked this question to,
uh,
people generation above me saying gen x and baby were worse.
The name they come up with is Bill Gates
and Bill Gates success story is not that much different than mine except in the
number of Zeros on our bank account statements.
So he had a very unique opportunity to play with early digital computers and I
think that he would claim or thank that Hah,
thank the people that gave him that opportunity for the numbers of zeroes that
he has on his bank account statement.
So it was,
I think play this sort of access to test and tinker in sort of unconstrained
environment that led him to at least his first unintentional success.
Of course,
what came after it was very intentional.
So my claim is that 20 years from now there'll be a quantum technology
equivalent of bill gates.
And that future leader is just an eight year old child today.
And that child will have access and opportunity to play with quantum technology
and come of age with this quantum technology revolution that's um,
my year old daughter and she's playing with,
uh,
a quantum computer so that IBM has a cloud based,
small comp,
quantum computing device that you can go and play with and there's this
graphical editor to create a quantum algorithms and you hit run and it runs on a
real quantum device.
So,
you know,
perhaps that person will be her,
but perhaps not.
The only thing I know is that it definitely won't if she's not given access to
it.
And so,
um,
that's my secret.
And um,
I'm confident that I dodged my fear of being an infomercial because I didn't
really give like a secret recipe and there wasn't a,
a one weird trick that's going to make life coaches angry or anything like that.
The answer I want to get to parents that there's no simple steps to become a
leader,
say in quantum technology or physics or,
or science more generally.
The road to success is not sort of laid out in front of you with the pave
stones.
I think that sort of road analogy is a really bad one.
Uh,
what I wanted to convey is that success is something kind of more what you build
up underneath you.
And that comes from is kind of like creating this scaffolding and spreading it
around you and as an adult were sort of free to create this variety for
ourselves of opportunities.
And I really think that we should,
and that's the thing I would tell,
tell parents is that one of the most important things is that you need to do
this because the important people in your life are the ones that are watching
and the ones that are learning and they need to see what it is to play and
tinker and really struggle,
I think with big ideas.
Thank you.
So your very first book,
what,
uh,
what inspired you?
How did you get started?
Right.
So the first book was quantum physics for babies and I certainly wouldn't have
done it if I hadn't had children on my own.
So I,
I was in,
uh,
a store and I saw us buying books for the kids and I saw some kind of technology
because of one of these like coding for kids books.
And I thought,
oh,
that's,
that's a great idea.
You know,
that's what I want.
I don't want anymore first farm animals books.
Um,
I want some,
some technology books.
And I started looking and seeing,
wow,
there's not,
not,
not that many available.
And I thought maybe,
maybe I could do this.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I'll just write about the science book and I'm starting to think about it.
And when the idea of quantum physics for babies popped into my mind,
I knew,
you know,
that's,
that's at least going to get some double takes.
So I think that's kind of how it started.
Action.
Um,
well,
when I started,
so I self published it initially,
so I,
you know,
I had copies myself and I would give them to my children's teachers and they
would,
they would look at it and they would kind of like squinting and then they would
laugh and then they would hand it back.
And I would say no,
it's a real,
real book.
Open,
open it up.
Um,
but I get,
I get lots of funny stories.
Um,
the funny ones are like stories of children repeating lines from the book in
public to people.
Um,
you know,
like kids arguing at the,
at the playground saying,
you know,
you're not made of energy.
I made of energy,
that sort of thing.
Um,
and then,
uh,
in the book that I showed you a good night lab,
I was drawing a picture of the grumpy old professor.
So in the book,
the grumpy old professors shouting,
publish,
uh,
so it's a parody of goodnight moon.
So if you remember good night moon,
there's a,
what is it?
An an old lady,
uh,
telling the child to shush.
So,
and good night lab,
it's a grumpy old professors shouting,
publish.
And someone tweeted me and said,
thanks a lot Chris.
Now my toddlers running around the house yelling at me to publish
and I thought,
yeah,
achievement.
I'm mark.
That was what I was going for it.
So my wife and I both to tell the operator Algebras and she is about to give
birth than two and a half,
three weeks ish.
So I was wondering,
how was it having a kid having to go in,
go to conferences?
How,
how was your personal life?
How was your life with that?
Sure.
I think that as an academic,
you on,
I mean,
this is,
this is different for every academic,
but I,
so I,
and in,
in,
in a sense,
I've been really lucky in having a lot of freedom.
I have this amazing partner who really,
really wants to stay at home and raise,
um,
raise their children.
And I was able to,
to take time off.
I mean,
my first two children were born when I was finishing my phd and I was nearing
the end,
so I was writing up and,
you know,
people don't expect you to be around anyways.
And so I could really be at home a lot.
And in many ways it was a transition for me because before all of my free time,
I feel like I don't have a better word for it,
but maybe wasted.
Um,
playing way too many video games and,
uh,
you know,
the,
the child comes along and now you have this extra responsibility and you're
like,
okay,
well I really need to finish this thesis because I'm going to need to start
earning money.
And,
and,
uh,
and so I felt like after the first child was born,
I was far more productive than I was before that.
And there's lots of times where you'll be able to get work done.
Maybe you don't want to get work done at night,
but as an academic,
you want to get work done at night where,
you know,
you can rock the Rock,
the thing with your foot and paper,
your thesis on the laptop.
So I've been,
I've been really lucky.
I mean,
I,
again,
I don't have a secret.
Thank you.
[inaudible].